i'm a political and social psychologist
i study how people understand the world
and what this means for society and for
democracy
which as it turns out is quite a lot
some people see the world as safe and
good
and this allows them to be okay with
uncertainty
and to take time to explore and play
others are acutely aware of threats in
their environment
so they prioritize order and
predictability
over openness and experimentation
my academic research i study how these
two approaches
shape how we think and feel about
everything from art
to politics i also explore how
political elites and partisan media use
these very differences
to engender hatred and fear and how the
economics of our media system
exploit these same divides but after
studying this i have come away
not with a sense that we are doomed to
be divided but that
it's up to us to see both sets of traits
as necessary and even valuable
take for example two men who have been
so influential
in my own life first my late husband
mike
he was an artist who saw the world as
safe and good
he welcomed ambiguity and play in his
life in fact we met through improv
comedy where he taught improvisers to
listen
and be open and to be comfortable not
knowing what was going to happen next
after we got married and had our baby
boy mike was diagnosed with a brain
tumor
and through months of hospitalizations
and surgeries
i followed mike's lead trying to
practice
being open trying to be okay not knowing
what was going to happen next
it was mike's tolerance for ambiguity
that allowed me to survive those months
of uncertainty
and that helped me explore new ways to
rebuild my life
after he died about a year and a half
after mike passed away i met my current
husband pj
pj is a criminal prosecutor who sees the
world
as potentially good provided that
threats are properly managed he also is
someone who embraces order and
predictability
in his daily routine in the foods that
he eats
in his selection of wardrobe and pj has
a vicious wit
but he's also morally very serious with
a strong sense of duty and purpose
and he values tradition loyalty
and family which is why at the age of 28
he did not hesitate to marry a widow
adopt her baby boy and raise him as his
son
it was pj's need for certainty and
closure
that brought stability to our lives
i share these two stories of mike and pj
not just because they're personal but
because they illustrate two things that
i have found in my own research
first that our psychological traits
shape how we engage with the world
and second that both of these approaches
make all of our lives possible
tragically though
political and economic incentives of our
media environment
seek to exploit these differences to get
us
angry to get our attention to get clicks
and to turn us against one another and
it works
it works in part because these same sets
of traits
are related to core political and
cultural beliefs
for years political psychologists have
studied how our psychological traits
shape our political beliefs we've
conducted experiments to understand how
our psychology
and our politics shape how we respond to
apolitical stimuli and this research has
shown that
those people who are less concerned with
threats who are tolerant of ambiguity
these people tend to be more culturally
and socially liberal
on matters like immigration or crime or
sexuality
and because they're tolerant of
ambiguity they also tend to be okay
with nuance and they enjoy thinking for
the sake of thinking
which helps explain why it is that there
are distinct aesthetic preferences
on the left and the right with liberals
more likely than conservatives to
appreciate things like
abstract art or even stories that lack a
clear ending
in my experimental work i've also found
that these differences
help explain why ironic political satire
is more likely to be appreciated and
understood
by liberals than conservatives on the
other hand
those people who are monitoring for
threats who prefer certainty and closure
those tend to be our political cultural
social conservatives because they're on
alert
they also make decisions quickly and
efficiently guided by intuition
and emotion and we found that these
traits help explain why conservatives
enjoy political opinion talk programming
that clearly and efficiently identifies
threats and enemies what is essential
though
is that these propensities are not
absolute
they're not fixed there are liberals who
are monitoring for threats
just as there are conservatives who are
tolerant of ambiguity
in fact pj's political beliefs are not
that radically different from those that
mike held
the link between psychology and politics
is contingent on context who we're with
and what's going on around us the
problem is that right now
our dominant context our political and
media context
actually needs these differences to be
absolute to be reinforced
and even to be weaponized
for reasons related to power and profit
some in politics and media want us to
believe that
those people who approach the world
differently from us
the mics or the pjs themselves are
dangerous
and social media platforms use
algorithms and micro targeting
to deliver divisive messages
in our preferred messaging aesthetic
messages that relate to politics culture
and race
and we see the devastating effects of
these messages every single day
americans who are angry and fearful of
the other side
charges of the other side destroying
america
but stop and think for a moment what
would happen
if those differences had never been
weaponized
it is liberal inclinations towards
openness and flexibility
that allow us to cope with uncertainty
and that allow us to explore new paths
towards innovation
creativity scientific discovery
think of things like space travel or
cures for diseases
or art that imagines and reimagines a
better world
and those conservative inclinations
towards
vigilance and security and tradition
these are the things that motivate us to
do what must be done
for our own protection and stability
think of the safety that's offered by
our armed forces
or the security of our banking system or
think about the stability that's offered
by such democratic institutions as
jury duty or cultural traditions like
fireworks on the 4th of july
what if the real threat posed to society
and democracy
is not actually posed by the other side
what if the real danger is posed by
political and media elites
who try to get us to think that we'd be
better off without the other side
and who use these divisions for their
own personal
financial political benefit
mike and pj engaged with the world very
differently
but these distinct approaches continue
to enrich my life every day
instead of our political and media
context
determining that the other side is the
enemy
and lulling us into believing that
that's true
what if we choose to create the context
real people connecting with other real
people
appreciating these two approaches for
what they are
necessary gifts that can help us all
survive
and thrive together
thank you